he's like Larson you're like coming into
this wanting to start sobbing crying
that is not what you like you wouldn't
just come up to me like you're like at a
birthday party around a ton of people it
wouldn't you as your own person wouldn't
just come up like sobbing crying like it
would just be over time something that
develops and most the time you're trying
not to cry that's the key so why are you
trying to come into this ball and crying
he's like quit it that is genius yes
because I've this helped me early on
yeah someone said human beings we don't
want to cry yeah we do everything not to
cry yes so as an actor you have to think
I'm supposed to cry in this scene and
you're like I don't want to do this I
don't want to do this blah blah and it's
just and it's and it comes out yeah and
you're like I don't want this to
and so that's if you play with that
totally that was the answer wasn't it
yes